this is the first look at the Karma
Rivero if you think you've seen it
before that's because this is the
resurrected version of the much loved
but ill-fated electric car formerly
known as the Fisker Karma once a rival
for Tesla Fisker Automotive went bust in
2013 and it seemed unlikely that would
ever see this beauty again but Chinese
auto parts giant Wang Sheng's scooped up
the defunct company's assets and created
karma automotive to bring the car back
to life the california-based outfit
believes it's fixed the endless problems
that plagued the original and tidy
things up a bit - one of the main iconic
features of our vehicle is the solar
panel roof previously it just powered
the 12-volt battery and linked with the
AC system this time so now 200 watts
solar roof that we have providing power
into the high voltage battery the car
still feels a bit like a concept
especially inside now often that's a
negative it means that it's unfinished
here it's a positive even if it means
less practicality but it's those quirky
bits that make this car feel special
they may be a bit retro futuristic but
karma is betting that they'll set the
rivero apart where the company can't
afford to be retro in any way is with
the drivetrain which we got to test out
gently and car number 10 off the new
line still wrapped in camel I love that
electric acceleration near-silent
pushes you back nicely into your seeds
there are no gear changes just talk put
your foot down and it goes
unlike a pure electric it's not silent
though you can hear that gas range
extender engine mooing upfront
occasionally so the engine cut in on
that last time when I've really put my
foot down and you can hear it it's like
a hybrid the engine is disconnected from
the drive literally in this case because
all the power from the engine is just
going to generating electricity to go to
the motors so it's always a little
disconcerting when the sound of the
engine doesn't exactly match to the
acceleration that you feel that you're
getting but that's actually the most
efficient way to use it the infotainment
system is all-new it's very responsive
it's got some fancy graphics to show you
where your drive energy is coming from a
plug-in hybrid which uses a gas engine
as a generator when the batteries are
flat was pretty special in 2011
now everyone's making them so back and
priced it over a hundred grand the car
has a lot to prove
karma is banking on the fact that
there's a lot of love for this design
and enough people with enough money will
forgive the checkered history and
embrace the new vehicle